for now here's what we're gonna find out
the folks under the most pressure
entering week 11 it also serves as a way
to preview some of the upcoming games
big cat has the trivia question I assume
I will probably get it wrong and then he
will get the first pick what do you got
okay this is a good one the Browns have
now defeated the Ravens and the Steelers
this year when was the last time they
beat them both in the same season since
coming back in the league in 1999 2014
[Music]
never never never never trick question
that's a trick question and actually the
way stat supposed to know that's a stats
is great at this but he didn't even have
to do the coming back from 1999 because
obviously the Browns never played the
ravens before 1999 right so the Browns
have never beaten the Ravens and the
Steelers in the same year am I supposed
to remember the results of four
different games yeah from every year for
20 years yeah correct i strenuously
object go ahead make first fire don't
actually stop doing the crying baby this
is triggering to me because my baby does
cry Mike there's four Super Bowls that
the Steelers and the Ravens have won and
that's time frame the Browns have been
terrible use your brain okay my first
pick is going to be Josh Lindy no the
Ravens have won two and the Steelers
have won too oh yeah you're right never
mind oh this is just this is were in a
third I was that I was confusing 1995
with 2005 I can't sorry I get known the
trivia question could have been Mike how
many Super Bowls have the Ravens and
Steelers won since 1999 and you would
have gotten that wrong I'm wiping the
floor with you today okay first up what
I just said is correct first up I'm
gonna say Indianapolis Jacksonville I'm
gonna pick both sides so it's going to
be the entire game this
we just talked about it a loser leaves
town game for the Rams bears the loser
of this game feels like they will be on
the outside looking in when it comes to
the playoff picture in a month and a
half's time the colts lose a game they
never ever should lose against Miami at
home the Jags have been sputtering
they're off of a bye this game it feels
like once it happens on Sunday we're
going to the winners say hey look out
for this team the loser they might be
done and the Colts were horrendous
against the Dolphins I don't know what
Brian Hoyer can do he's got to do better
than that I know they've dealt with a
lot of things this year I know obviously
Andrew Luck and Jacobi percent now
getting hurt but you got to find a way
to win that game if you want to be in
the playoff picture come late December
so I'm saying pressure game for both
sides for me the big pressure is on
Jason Garrett the Cowboys head coach
because in one moment on Sunday night
when they had those two ridiculous
running calls when they had second in
two or three from the Minnesota 11 they
called a run to Ezekiel Ali that didn't
work in another run to Ezekiel that went
backward fourth down they didn't get at
the Vikings win the game
the Cowboys fall to five before they're
in a tie now with the Eagles you look at
the schedule the rest of the way I'd
give the Eagles the edge to win that
division and I think if you don't win
the NFC East you're not getting in the
playoffs as a wild-card and if the
Cowboys don't get in the playoffs of the
wild card
Jason Garrett's out of a job so every
game the rest of the way intense
pressure on Jason Garrett especially in
games that he should win they are
becoming the ultimate team this year
that wins the game that they should and
it loses the games that they should when
they come up against a good team they
lose but for their loss to the Jets that
pattern is held I don't know where this
one fits they probably should win this
game and if they don't it throws
everything off they fall to five and
five and even though the Eagles quite
possibly will lose to the Patriots this
is one of those games that the Cowboys
are going to need when it's time to put
the schedules up against each other in
the end result of the season to see who
wins that division they blow this one it
may increase significantly the chances
the Cowboys don't make it to the
playoffs which means Jason
doesn't make it to 2020 that's a great
pic Mike and I agree with you Jason
Garrett has a team that is
underperforming underachieving because
they have a ton of talent I'll also
throw in their mic this is similar to
the Jacksonville indie game I think it's
it's dual side pressure because Matt
Patricia if his defense can't get fixed
quickly that's gonna be a big issue for
him because he brought it was brought in
as a defensive coach he was brought in
as a guy that was supposed to instill
you know the patriot way and it hasn't
worked through a year and a half and I
think that Matt Stafford has been
fantastic this year whether he plays or
not you know he has been awesome the
defense has has failed them and that's
Matt Patricia's specialty so that's a
dual pressure game as well I'll go out
to the west coast Mike I think Jimmy
Garoppolo is under a little bit of
pressure this week he had a bad game on
Monday night it felt like he was going
to throw an interception on every play
in those last few drives Jimmy Garoppolo
the the 49ers are such a talented team
that they go up and down with where
Jimmy Garoppolo can take them they have
all the defensive talent they need they
probably don't have a ton of skilled
positions but once they get George kiddo
back who's not gonna be playing this
week they have enough so it's really up
to Jimmy Garoppolo and can he elevate
himself to that level and guess what his
great game was two weeks ago against the
Cardinals these Cardinals team he's
playing this week so can he do the same
thing he did two weeks ago on Thursday
Night Football or whatever it was three
weeks ago and elevate his game after a
bad outing on Monday night against the
Seahawks but you're right he's got to
get it back on track so this doesn't
become a trend and the team is good
enough to win plenty of games without
him having big performances he's kind of
the Kirk Cousins of the 49ers where we
have the running game we have the
defense just don't get in the way don't
screw things up and if we're lucky we
won't need you to step up and make big
throws in big spots to try to win games
when you look at that last drive they
had in overtime three incomplete passes
that left plenty of time on the clock
for the Seahawks to score the
game-winning field goal but two of them
were so inaccurate yeah Dante Pettis he
missed him and he had debo Samuel
wide-open it would have been walk into
the end zone
touch
down end the game what a moment that
would have been he under throw him so we
need to see more from Jimmy Garoppolo or
he really does have to worry about Kyle
Shanahan and John Lynch deciding after
the season that they can find an upgrade
out there and that he's the weak link on
a team that otherwise is ready to win a
championship all right speaking of Kirk
Cousins I hate to pick on him but I've
given him plenty of praise this week III
was torn between Mike Zimmer and Kirk
Cousins I'm gonna go Kirk Cousins
because Vic Fangio the Broncos head
coach swept the Vikings last year when
he was the Bears defensive coordinator
and and now that Cousins has reversed
the narrative as it relates to winning
against quality opponents on the road in
prime time you cannot stub your toe
against a team you should be there
heading into their bye week some of
these guys may be thinking let's get
this game over with so I can get a few
days off they need to stay focused and
the leadership can't only come from the
coaching staff the quarterback has to
hold guys accountable and ensure that
everyone is buttoned up and on their P's
and Q's and ready to do everything
because they are the superior team but I
think back to last year the Vikings were
17 point favorites against the Buffalo
Bills in Week three the bills scored
early and the Vikings could never answer
the bell and the Bills won that game
easily the Vikings need to guard against
that their double digit favorites they
should win this game easily this is a
game where the pressure is on Kirk
Cousins to not follow his signature win
in Minnesota with what would be his
signature to feat okay no surprise here
but I actually had the Vikings in that
game against the bills when they were 17
point favorites and then lost out right
another good pick Mike you're on fire
this it does feel like that spot where
Kirk Cousins will have a letdown so to
have have the momentum going forward
going into the bye week is huge they
have some winnable games coming off the
buy after they play Seattle which it can
be tough in Seattle but they have
Detroit and the Chargers after that my
last one I'm gonna go with the New
Orleans Saints I think what the Saints
do in this bounce back after being
embarrassed by the Falcons who had one
win before Sunday's game will be very
interesting and indicative of where the
Saints season is heading the New Orleans
Saints I think most people would
agree are one of the cream-of-the-crop
teams in the NFC the New Orleans Saints
have also had three games this year Mike
three games where their offense has not
produced a touchdown that doesn't feel
like a cream of the crop team so I'm
going to think that I'm gonna be
watching this game this weekend and
saying what the Saints do on offense
against a very suspect Tampa Bay
secondary their run defense is very good
shout-out Steven Shea but what they do
on offense is going to be a huge sign to
what comes for the Saints going down the
stretch because this is a game they
should win and they should win easily
and if they don't there will be a lot of
questions going here and Teddy
Bridgewater was undefeated as a starter
may I remind you so let's see how this
goes all right the line that's a good
pick and I agree with you completely in
the last one for middle one I I know we
are getting along we fought so much for
the first hour and a half we got to try
to mend fences so we don't end up
sending each other
profane text messages on Friday yes so
not that we've ever done that but who
knows I don't think he's ever made an
appearance on this draft and I'm
reluctant to even do it but I have to
put Bill Belichick on the list and
here's one here's look lost by 17 to the
Ravens the last time we saw the Patriots
the Ravens are just one game behind them
and the number one seed could go away
they may have to go back to Baltimore in
the playoffs and here company he's got
two weeks to get ready for the Eagles
the last time he had two weeks to get
ready for the Eagles he lost a Super
Bowl this is kind of a shot at
redemption and his defense is better
than it was it can't be much worse than
it was that day in Minnesota in February
of 2018 but he's got a better defense
the Eagles aren't as good as they were
then Carson Wentz not nicked Falls but
it's still Peterson against Belichick
and the pressure is on Belichick to show
that he used that full two weeks to
address the weaknesses on the team the
offensive line has not been good their
offense overall has not carried its
weight what has Belichick done and how
is he guarding against what the Eagles
may do because we talked about this
yesterday I think the Eagles are gonna
unleash Carson Wentz they're gonna throw
caution to the wind they saw what a
mobile quarterback did against the
Patriots two weeks ago in Lamar Jackson
you forget about Carson Wentz possibly
getting injured for three hours on
Sunday
let Wentz run circles around the
Patriots defense and hope that you can
out score them so there's gonna be a
real test for Bill Belichick and if they
lose their second in a row they really
do have to start worrying about whether
or not they're going to get that one
seat and then you start having to worry
possibly about not getting a bye at all
and having to host a wild card game to
start the the playoff run the last time
they hosted a wild card game they got
blown off the field by the Ravens all
right well Mike it's a good good news is
that we're being nice to each other in
this segment because if we weren't I
would probably say that's a terrible
pick and you're an idiot but I'm not
going to so good pick Mike
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports